«L’invention ne consiste pas à créer
à partir du néant mais à partir du chaos.»
D'un côté, il y a un créateur. Mary Shelley.
Mary Wollstonecraft, William Godwin, Percy
Shelley, Viktor Frankenstein. De l'autre,
la créature. Frankenstein ou le mythe du
Prométhée moderne. Son monstre. L'histoire
de Mary, ses sentiments, son œuvre, sa postérité.
La créature est raccommodée, assemblée
à partir d'une multitude de pièces, d'idées,
d'inspirations et d'expériences. La vie de
Mary Shelley a construit Frankenstein, et
nous allons reconstruire ici la vie de Mary
Shelley.
Mary Wollstonecraft-Godwin est née le 30
août 1797 près de Londres.
J'ai déjà raconté dans mon précédent
Gentes Dames Badass la vie de ses parents:sa
mère, pionnière du féminisme anglais, meurt
dix jours après sa naissance et la laisse
avec son père et sa demi-soeur Fanny, issue
d'une première liaison de sa mère.
Son père se remarie par la suite ce qui lui
vaut une nouvelle demi-soeur, Claire Clairmont,
dont elle est très proche.
Elle a la chance de grandir dans une famille
favorisée, même si elle ne fait pas partie
de la bourgeoisie, et surtout en plein dans
le milieu intellectuel et littéraire de l'époque:
son père est éditeur et possède une bibliothèque
impressionnante qui permet à Mary d'apprendre
très tôt le latin, le grec, le français,
l'italien... Il veille à ce que ses enfants
aient une bonne éducation, en leur enseignant
à domicile, et reçoit de nombreux auteurs
et philosophes qui renforcent l'ouverture
d'esprit de Mary. Dans une lettre, il dit
d'elle «Je tiens à ce qu'elle soit élevée
comme une philosophe, voire comme une cynique.»
Mary grandit cependant dans l'ombre de ces
deux personnages: son père, auquel elle
voue une grande admiration, et sa mère dont
il entretient la mémoire. La perte de sa
mère et les nombreux décès atour d'elle
qu'elle subit tout au long de sa vie en font
une femme au cœur fréquemment brisé, très
éloquente un moment puis brusquement mélancolique,
détestant se donner en spectacle et éprouvant
souvent le besoin de se mettre à l'abri du
monde, comme sur la tombe de sa mère où
elle se rend souvent.
Mary a 16 ans lorsqu'elle rencontre Percy
Shelley.
Il vient d'une famille aristocratique avec
laquelle il est en froid, comme beaucoup de
jeunes aristos qui ne se conforment pas à
l'avenir conventionnel tracé par les parents,
et qui fréquente la librairie de son père
dont il admire le travail.
Très vite, c'est le coup de foudre, mais
le père de Mary tente de la dissuader de
cette relation: Percy est marié, même
s'il ne vit plus avec sa femme, qui est enceinte
de surcroît.
D'un autre côté, ses parents ont longtemps
avancé des idées très libérales à l'encontre
du mariage et Mary est tentée de suivre leurs
traces. Percy, lui, prône l'amour libre,
le polyamour qui ne porte pas encore ce nom,
et aimerait entraîner Mary dans cette idée.
Ils s'enfuient donc en 1814, alors que Mary
a à peine 17 ans, avec sa sœur Claire qui
les accompagne.
Tout au long de leur histoire, ils seront
partagés entre un désir de révolte, de
liberté, mais aussi une recherche de conformité:
Mary n'a aucun problème à vivre avec un
homme marié mais ne supporte pas qu'il aille
voir ailleurs, les ménages à plusieurs...
Elle adhère à ses idées d'amour libre,
mais ne cherche pas à être avec quelqu'un
d'autre que lui bien qu'il l'encourage à
fréquenter d'autres hommes. Elle veut des
enfants mais doit supporter le fait que la
femme légitime de Percy accouche d'un fils
alors qu'elle perd trois des quatre enfants
qu'elle a avec Percy.
En cela elle se rapproche de sa mère, défenseuse
des conditions féminines mais qui meurt en
accouchant et se voit avant ça obligée de
se marier pour légitimer sa fille face à
la société.
La société ne voit pas d'un meilleur œil
la vie de Mary, Percy et Claire. Ils voyagent,
en France, en Allemagne, et en Italie que
Mary aime beaucoup.
Les années passant, elle est de plus en plus
déprimée. Par la perte de ses deux autres
enfants, son seul fils à atteindre l'âge
adulte naissant en 1819, par le comportement
de Pecy vis à vis des autres femmes.
Elle accepte le fait qu'il en fréquente d'autres
qu'elle et devient même amie avec l'une d'elles,
mais supporte mal qu'il leur dédie des poèmes.
D'autres deuils viennent obscurcir ce tableau:
le suicide de Fanny, sa demi-sœur, et de
la femme de Percy, qui leur permet tout de
même de se marier en 1816.
A l'été 1822, alors qu'ils sont en Italie,
Percy achète un voilier avec des amis et
décide de naviguer vers la Toscane. Le temps
est mauvais, Percy ne sait pas nager: ils
sont retrouvés sur une plage dix jours plus
tard. Il est incinéré sur la plage, et Mary
conserve son cœur jusqu'à sa mort. Littéralement.
Durant tout le reste de sa vie, elle porte
le deuil de Percy. Ses derniers mots dans
le journal qu'elle tenait depuis sa fuite
en 1814 sont «Oh Shelley, pourquoi m'as-tu
abandonnée?»
Dans tous ses romans et plus encore après
sa mort, on retrouve une idée de deuil et
de solitude, comme dans le Dernier Homme,
un roman post-apocalyptique décrivant le
dernier homme au monde. Elle arrête d'écrire
en 1839 après avoir terminé son œuvre:
la publication des œuvres complètes et annotées
de Percy Shelley, qui contribuent grandement
à faire connaître ses écrits.
Mais, ne manque-t-il pas une certaine créature
à toute cette histoire, me direz-vous?
J'ai choisi de parler de toute son histoire
avec Percy en premier pour vous situer les
sentiments de Mary et la nature de leurs relations,
mais revenons un peu en arrière:
Nous sommes en 1816, sur les bords du lac
de Genève. A cette époque, c'est un lieu
de résidence réputé pour les anglais marginaux,
à la vie scandaleuse, les rock stars d'aujourd'hui.
Et le groupe qui passe l'été au bord du
lac rentre tout à fait dans ces critères:
Percy se drogue, Mary et lui ne sont toujours
pas mariés.
Lord Byron, qui les invite, est un aristocrate
et poète à la réputation tellement sulfureuse
qu'il est obligé de quitter l'Angleterre,
quelle idée d'être ouvertement bisexuel.
Ils sont accompagnés de Claire et de John
Polidori, amants de Byron. Tous les deux,
ou seulement Claire, ça ne l'est pas. Clair.
L'été s'annonce joyeux, fait de promenades
en bateau sur le lac et de randonnées, mais
la météo en décide autrement. Elle est
particulièrement horrible cette année là,
on est en plein dans le petit âge glaciaire
et l'éruption d'un volcan en Indonésie contribue
à perturber le climat.
L'atmosphère autour de la villa tourne donc
à l'orage littéralement et symboliquement:
on s'ennuie, Byron traite Polidori comme son
souffre-douleur et se dispute régulièrement
avec lui. Avec Claire, aussi, dont il s'éloigne.
Ils visitent cependant certains lieux qui
inspirent Mary par la suite: le glacier
du Mont Blanc, un laboratoire d'expériences
sur l'électricité. Deux ans plus tôt Mary
avait aussi visité un certain château en
Bavière, ayant appartenu à une famille Frankenstein.
«Rien n'est plus pénible à l'esprit humain,
après que les sentiments ont été surexcités
par une succession rapide d’événements,
que le calme plat de l'inaction.»
Pour passer le temps à la villa, le groupe
lit des romans gothiques, brûlant ceux qu'ils
jugent mal écrits, jusqu'à ce que Byron
propose une idée: un concours d'écriture,
chacun devra écrire une histoire de fantôme
qu'ils pourront lire et éventuellement publier
ensemble.
Byron veut écrire une histoire de vampire,
Mary boit du vin d'opium pour trouver l'inspiration.
Elle se sert beaucoup de ses rêves comme
source d'idées pour ses histoires.
Et puis elle se met à écrire, les jours
suivants, et ne s'arrête plus. Percy l'encourage,
et la convainc de faire de sa nouvelle un
roman. Finalement, de ce concours, Claire
et Percy n'écrivent rien; Byron ne rédige
que quelques notes de brouillon sur le mythe
du vampire, que Polidori reprend ensuite pour
en faire le premier roman vampirique anglais
mais qui ne lui apporte aucune gloire.
A la fin de l'été Byron part vers l'Italie.
Les autres rentrent en Angleterre, et Mary
continue d'écrire. Elle publie finalement
Frankenstein ou le mythe du Prométhée Moderne
en 1818, qui rencontre un succès immédiat.
Le concours de Byron est un prétexte, accompagné
d'une atmosphère qui plonge Mary dans un
état d'esprit propice à l'écriture, mais
il est probable que Mary aurait écrit Frankenstein
quoi qu'il en soit, car ce sont tous les éléments
de sa vie qui ont formé la genèse de son
livre. Des poètes marginaux réunis à l'été
1816, seules Claire et Mary survivent: John
Polidori se suicide en 1821, Percy Shelley
meurt en bateau comme on l'a déjà vu, et
lord Byron meurt de fièvre en Grèce en 1824.
"Maudit soit le jour où j'ai reçu la vie!
ai-je hurlé. Maudit soit mon créateur! Même
TOI, qui m'a fait, je te dégoûte! Dieu à
créé l'homme à son image, mais moi je suis
la forme corrompue de la tienne, plus horrible
même ! Satan a des compagnons pour l'admirer
et le suivre, moi je reste solitaire et haï."
Le premier roman de Mary Shelley a été construit
à partir d'un tas de matériaux existants.
Pour ce qui est des courants littéraires,
on peut y retrouver une forte influence gothique
évidemment, mais dont elle se détache en
écrivant son récit à la première personne,
qui rapproche davantage le lecteur des personnages
et de leurs angoisses. Elle est aussi à rapprocher
des récits de voyages, des contes philosophiques,
et même des romans de science-fiction dont
Frankenstein serait l'ancêtre. Elle emprunte
aussi à des mythes existants: celui de
Prométhée, auquel le titre fait directement
référence, et le paradis perdu de Milton
que le monstre lit au point de s'identifier
au personnage de Satan.
Tout comme son monstre, son roman est couturé
de différentes influences anciennes tout
en s'ancrant dans la science de l'époque:
elle fait référence à Darwin et surtout
aux travaux d'électricité galvanique, très
en vogue à l'époque, qui montrent que la
matière vivante répond à l'électricité.
Au début du XIXe siècle, des expériences
étaient réalisées sur des cadavres d'animaux
ou de condamnés pour provoquer des mouvements
et on en venait à se demander si la résurrection
serait un jour possible par ce biais.
Outre le château qu'elle avait visité en
Bavière, Frankenstein pourrait alors faire
référence à Franklin, l'inventeur du paratonnerre.
Elle tire donc aussi son récit de sa propre
expérience, à partir des voyages qu'elle
avait réalisés en Suisse, en Allemagne,
en Italie mais aussi à partir de son approche
de la mort et du deuil qu'elle a côtoyés
de près à plusieurs reprises. On le retrouve
dans le sentiment de solitude qui parcourt
toutes ses œuvres, de Frankenstein à The
Last Man on Earth, et dans les histoires d'amour
impossibles qu'elle met en scène: entre
Victor et Elizabeth, entre la créature et
le créateur...
On peut ainsi faire beaucoup de parallèles
entre son roman et sa propre vie: «T'ais-je
demandé, créateur, de me produire?»
fait-elle dire à son monstre tout en dédiant
son récit à son père, William Godwin. La
première personne tuée par le monstre se
nomme aussi William, tout comme aurait dû
s'appeler le fils de Godwin et Mary Wollstonecraft
s'ils en avaient eu un à la place de Mary.
Lorsque Frankenstein est publié, elle le
décrit comme «ma hideuse progéniture
que je jette maintenant dans le monde»,
et fait de même dire à Victor à propos
de sa création: «Je ne voyais en cet
être que mon propre vampire».
Lorsqu'il sort en 1818, Frankenstein est publié
anonymement. Le public pense d'abord que l'auteur
en est Percy Shelley, puisqu'il en a signé
la première préface, et puisque le livre
est dédié à William Godwin, le mentor de
Percy. On a du mal à croire qu'il ait pu
être écrit par une femme, et on trouve surtout
cela dommage, parce qu'une telle histoire
l'éloigne fort de «la douceur inhérente
à son sexe». On dit d'elle qu'elle est
sous l'influence de son père, de Percy, et
tous ses autres ouvrages portent simplement
la mention «par l'auteur de Frankenstein».
Son père refuse longtemps qu'elle signe ses
romans du nom de Mary Shelley: on l'appelle
parfois du nom de sa mère, et elle ne signe
enfin de son propre nom qu'en 1844 à la mort
de son père.
Malgré ses sept romans, ses contes, récits,
nouvelles, les journaux qu'elle tenait, Mary
reste occultée par l'image de Frankenstein,
son premier roman, et ses autres œuvres restent
peu connues jusqu'à la fin du Xxe siècle.
Jusqu'au bout, fiction et réalité se mêlent
dans sa vie: le monstre, qu'on appelle souvent
Frankenstein à tord, occulte et dépasse
son créateur; et le roman Frankenstein
occulte Mary Shelley.